I was welcomed back, uh, welcomed back from
my vacation last week to yet another day of
massive stock market crashes on Friday. My
mutual fund account looking very, very ugly.
And at first I wasn't sure what had caused
it because I wasn't following the news last
week since we were on break, the Dow was down
in other more than 600 points, the Nasdaq
and s and p 500 and the Russell 2000 all down,
uh, the same or more on a percentage basis.
And then on my flight home I started catching
up on news, getting ready for the week of
shows and realized, Oh yeah, Donald Trump
once again, scaling up the trade war and straight
up tweeting fascistic threats about controlling
American companies.
And once again, stocks are taking a dive.
Donald Trump, yes, putting even more self-destructive
tariffs on China. But before doing that, take
a look at what the president of the United
States tweeted quote, our country has lost
stupidly trillions of dollars with China over
many years. They have stolen our intellectual
property at our rate of hundreds of billions
of dollars a year. And they want to continue.
I won't let that happen. We don't need China
and frankly would be far better off without
them. The vast amounts of money made and stolen
by China from the United States year after
year for decades will and must stop. Here's
the key part. Our great American companies
are hereby ordered to immediately start looking
for an alternative to China, including bringing
your company's home and making your products
in the u s say, okay, it goes on from there.
The key part is American companies are here
by ordered to immediately look for alternatives
to China.
What does that mean? It's completely perplexing
from a legal point of view. First of all,
as a tweet, does it count as a policy? Is
it a formal directive? The consensus is no,
it doesn't. Uh, but it still sounds official
when you see the president saying companies
are hereby ordered, but as a tweet alone,
it is not law or a formal directive in and
of itself. But then the question is, is that
something Donald Trump is going to do? What
is the legal basis for ordering companies
to not deal with China? Is this some kind
of de facto sanctions without actually putting
in place sanctions? Is he threatening to put
in place those real types of sanctions, which
would be just an implosive act when it comes
to the American economy, which I'll explain
in more detail momentarily. This is the type
of thing that actually happens in fascist
dictatorships.
It's the sort of mob style, authoritarian
national politic, and then income. The tariffs,
once again, escalating these back and forth.
Retaliatory tariffs from China on the U S
and from the u s on China to our detriment.
October one tariffs on 250 billion in imports
go from 25 to 30% destructive. September one
$300 billion will be taxed at 15% instead
of 10% understand there is no off ramp here.
This is crushing farmers. This is bad for
builders. This is bad for all sorts of everyday
Americans. We are told that eventually these
tariffs will be so destructive to China that
China will cave and come to Trump begging
and pleading and Trump's going to win and
everybody is going to be happy. It's not going
to happen. Understand that a ton of the stuff
that we sell to China, they can get elsewhere
or they can make themselves. They're already
turning to other countries for some building
materials.
They're making energy deals with Russia. The
things we get from China would be way more
expensive to either make here or get elsewhere.
We don't have the leverage. This is not a
political analysis. This is an economic reality.
This is sort of like a mob dispute except
here one side has no leverage but doesn't
get it in the mob. Oftentimes they know when
they're beat. They know when they don't have
leverage and they adjust their behavior. Trump's
behaving like a mob boss with leverage, but
he doesn't have it and we're increasingly
out in this triangle of the world's superpowers,
China, Russia, and the u s China and Russia
increasingly working together more and more
while the United States is ignored and out
and self-destructing with Donald Trump's trade
policy. No one is denying that China has a
human rights issue. No one is denying that
they are doing horrible things when it comes
to intellectual property, but this is just
the logistical reality.
They can bounce back from this trade war way
more easily than we can. The markets are seeing
it. We do not have the leverage and Trump
ignores that. We have a trade deficit with
China for a reason. This is like a fundamental
misunderstanding. Trump says, look at our
trade deficit with China. We import from them
much more than we export. That's the definition
of a trade deficit. That's a sign that we
are losing to China. We designed our economy
to have a trade deficit with China. What I
mean is we can import tons of cheap stuff
from them and it's good for our economy in
a particular way. There's good and bad to
all of these arrangements. This type of situation
has winners and losers in different ways,
but Republicans and Democrats both wanted
a trade deficit. Even if they didn't say we
want a trade deficit in that.
The whole point was let's get a bunch of stuff
from China because it's so cheap, and then
we can make it available in the United States
to people at far lower costs than they would
be if we were to manufacture ourselves or
in higher cost of production countries. Republicans
and Democrats both wanted it. We knew that
it would have a jobs cost and it has, and
that's a perfectly reasonable debate to have.
But Donald Trump doesn't understand that Donald
Trump doesn't have an off ramp from the, from
the trade, uh, from the tariffs, the trade
war. Donald Trump doesn't understand that
we have a trade deficit for a reason. It's
not just China is winning, or China has us
over a barrel. And sadly, Trump's ignorant
base never got it. When Trump bragged about
his expertise, when it comes to trade, they
still don't get it and they'll probably still
vote to reelect the guy in 2020. But this
is the reality. The markets are suffering
everyday. People are suffering, farmers are
suffering. People that work for home builders
are suffering and Trump doesn't even seem
to have the capacity to understand the mechanics
behind it. Let me know what you think. I'm
on Twitter at the pacman. The show is on twitter@davidpakmanshowandmakesureyoufollowmeontwitchattwitch.tv
slash David Pakman at least a couple of lives.
Great happening this week on Twitter, the
David Pakman show@davidpakmandotcomthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com